Then we carry that to the field for five years and when we saw this down what we get is $862 + 6`.
Hey everyone! Have you ever wondered how much do you'll earn if you save a little bit today and what that translates to a couple years from now? Or have you ever wondered how much you need to save in order to reach a particular goal?
Well with compounding and discounting we can achieve those types of answers let's go ahead and start with compounding.
And compounding simply tells us what we can expect to earn off of a current sum of money so this is going to tell us.
The future value of some present value of money.
Multiply that by 1 plus whatever the interest rate happens to be in our stands for the interest rate.
And we multiply that by the number of time periods that we are looking at to keep this simple weirdest going to use this as the number of years that were trying to forecast out to so let's say that I have currently $1,000.
So this is my present value money and let's also say that the interest rate is 3% and the way that we write that here is we are going to say it is 0.03 and we want to know.
In five years what does this translate to buy give my bank $1,000 at 3% interest what can I expect to earn in 5 years so what bet into our formula.
And that is going to give us $1,000 * 1 + 0.03 a in a raise that to the 5th and when we saw this out that gives us $1,159.27 so just believing the money in the bank at 3% interest over the course of five years we will have a positive $159.27 other things to consider you can add more to this 1,000 which is going to speed up or increase the amount that we end up with at 5 years we do have inflation that we have to worry about so that 3% interest may actually go down to maybe 2% interest because of inflation and slice their roads of money so that's something to keep in mind and something that businesses do keep in mind whenever they are. Taking these types of Investments.
Compounding is discount.
Discounting is going to say hey what is the present value.
Of a future stream of money.
What is the present value of a future stream of money so instead of like what we had here with the present values X.
My one plus the interest rate we are now going to divide the future value.
By the interest rate over the amount of time that we are considerate so let's again say hey.
In the future I'm going to need $1,000 for the future value I need $1,000 for some project that I'm going to have coming up in 5 years I know the interest rate is going to be.
3% light but we last had and we're going to keep our time to be the same as well 5 years.
And now we simply pluck all of that is going to have the present value is equal to 1000 divided by 1 + 0.03 that's at 3 and then we carry that to the 5th or 5 years and when we saw this down what we get is $862.61 so that's a $1,000 5 years from now.